things seem to be going really well with
the institution of the Art Museum all
the big cities have one new ones are
popping up constantly and the lines to
get into blockbuster shows can snake
around the block but despite the buzz
museums are arguably not doing as much
for us as they might their whole purpose
and function in modern society has been
left oddly rather unexplored many of us
show up at these museums more out of
guilt than genuine pleasure the prestige
of art as opposed to any spontaneous
enthusiasm is what seems to keep a
sizeable share of people coming through
the doors and a lot of the more recent
art on display can be deeply puzzling to
behold even if we don't generally reveal
our confusion for fear of seeming
foolish at the heart of the problem of
the Art Museum is an institutional
inability to define in simple terms what
art might actually be for and quite why
it should matter so much we may be
heartily convinced of art's importance
but we have a devilishly hard time
pinning the significance down here is a
suggestion the purpose of art is
therapeutic art is there to lend
inspiration and consolation in relation
to a number of the challenges of being
human art helps us to cope with among
other things our inability to focus on
what's beautiful and precious in life
our tendency to caricature others and
forget about their sufferings our
inclination to lose hold of our inherent
creativity and playfulness are
frustrated longings to create better
societies and our need for stillness
perspective and solemnity in an angry
chaotic world even though it may be
fashionable to say otherwise art is
definitely not there just for art's sake
it is a tool to help us to live and die
well it opens our eyes it returns us to
a sense of creativity it connects us
with strangers it shakes us from
political complacency it stills are
agitated hearts art has a healing
function this gives us all we need to
define what an art museum should be an
institution that displays and arranges
art in ways that can steal its audiences
such a stark and deliberately vulgar
definition has revolutionary
implications currently most art museums
are laid out chronologically as if the
most important thing about works of art
was when they were made but with a
better focus on the function of art
worse could now be rearranged according
to the distinctive troubles of the soul
they can help us with there could be a
gallery devoted to addressing the
Agony's of love another focused on
helping us cope with anxiety
a third devoted to issues of envy a
fourth to aging and so on entire museums
might bite off one part of a therapeutic
emotional curriculum there might be a
museum for calm that would collect a
range of works that help to usher in
this prized mood from across all
centuries in media there could be a
museum for creativity a museum for
friendship and so on so I might be very
big others quite small they might exist
online or in a narrow space between a
pub and a kebab shop you often hear it
said that museums of art are our new
cathedrals in other words that art can
heal us as religions once did it's an
intriguing and vital idea but one which
art museums sadly haven't actually taken
up because while they expose us to
objects of genuine importance they seem
unable to curate them in ways that link
them powerfully to our inner needs our
new cathedrals are underperforming
we should give up on the idea of the art
museum as some kind of dead storage
space for the history of the subject or
a whitewashed cavern that stays
intimidatingly silent as to its real
purpose the art museum deserves to be
reborn as a kind of superior chemist or
drug store that vividly signposts art
and culture and uses it to bring
inspiration solace and meaning to our
confused anxious and troubled societies
you